well Memorial Day Weekend marks The
Unofficial start of summer for Americans
over in the UK they have the Chelsea
flower show and it's happening right now
it's the country's most prestigious
garden show started in 1913 and is in
full bloom apparently weeds yes weeds
are the new in thing as Raymond ascencio
found out sustainability is a theme
that's getting louder each year
award-winning Gardens to inspire better
well-being and a better planet
these are some of the three dozen Best
in Show at the UK's most prestigious
Garden event the Chelsea flower show is
a really kind of mad very British I
think eccentric mix designer Tom Massey
wants us to see the world through an
insect's point of view the world is in
an insect Armageddon insects are so
vital to our food security they
pollinate our food these pollinators
need flowering plants not just beautiful
blooms but weeds he says that should be
welcomed it's a term that is essentially
just saying a plant that's going in the
wrong place but it really is a plant
going in the in the right place
and needed now a new frame of mind from
Weeds as enemies of perfection to Heroes
for biodiversity it's amazing the the
kind of ecosystems that emerge and
develop if you just leave things King
Charles might agree a champion of
conservation he attended the Chelsea
flower show for the first time as
monarch
Queen Elizabeth opens the Chelsea flower
show following a long Royal tradition
designer G.A huang's gold medal winning
slice of Korean Forest stressed a return
to Nature and Reliance on Herbal Healing
before modern medicine the mountain was
our Pharmacy she said just like the
Native Americans
angelain ricard's silver medal-winning
Garden of bamboo and medicinal plants
reminds us no action is too small people
think oh I've only got a small garden
doesn't make any difference but if you
talk to your neighbor and your neighbor
and your neighbor and your neighbor and
you all start thinking about what you
can do plant-wise to increase your
Wildlife all of a sudden you've created
a green Corridor and these are the
things that make a difference and there
is power in the people for positive
change nearly 40 percent of the UK are
gardeners about 27 million people so if
it's gardeners we all start to come
together we can have a huge net Effect
one Garden weeds included at a time for
CBS Saturday morning raymie inocencio
London
weeds are our friend they are and they
can be beautiful too yeah I mean a lot
of people such Variety in that and
that's fear I'm gonna feel better now
the weeds in my little garden me too
it's a plus I don't have a garden sorry